hey you guys movie review time once
again this is my flickers of fear show
the movie that we're talking about today
this is one that i had actually been
looking forward to for a really long
time and i'm glad that i finally got a
chance to see it and it was actually
even better than i was expecting this is
a movie that came out back in 2019
and it's called extraordinary and it's a
horror comedy
now i don't remember when i first
started hearing about this i think it
premiered at south by southwest back in
2019 sometime and i remember it having
like kind of a lot of buzz like in the
horror community with a lot of people
saying you know oh this is a really
great movie and i kind of feel like at
the end of the year it turned up on a
lot of people's like favorite movies
that they had seen that year even though
it didn't really get a wide release
until later on
so i put it on my list probably sometime
back in 2019 or maybe 2020 and i said
well i'll get around to it one of these
days because it sounded really funny
but it seemed like it was a little bit
hard to get hold of where you had to pay
to rent it and things like that so i was
very happy that probably a week or two
ago shutter actually at least in the
united states added it to their lineup i
believe it was on netflix in the uk i
don't know if it is anymore but i saw
that like some british reviewers uh had
said that it had come on netflix i don't
think it's on netflix in the us but
shutter just added it in the united
states so i finally sat down and watched
it and what a [ __ ] delight this movie
is
uh it has i will note it has 98
uh fresh on rotten tomatoes and
sometimes that means something and
sometimes it doesn't in this case i
think that's completely justified yes
there's probably gonna be some crabby
[ __ ] somewhere that are like oh
they don't think it's funny or whatever
but
honestly this is just such
it's just such a warm
lovable like hilarious type of movie
that
i don't know to me it just seems like a
very hard movie to not like
but i mean i know there's going to be
some that don't but i feel like
i don't feel too nervous about
recommending this uh to people that
really like horror comedies because this
is actually one of the most charming uh
and funniest ones that i've ever seen
i'm especially gonna recommend it if you
like stuff like
ghostbusters or
the frighteners or sean of the dead
or
what we do in the shadows something like
that it's like that kind of sense of
humor to it so it sort of has that bro
that dry british thing going on it's an
irish film
but it also has a little bit of like
over-the-top
kind of like surrealist absurdist type
[ __ ] going on too i kind of feel like
mainly like one very minor criticism
that some people gave it i didn't have
this but some people i could see where
they were coming from uh said that they
didn't think those two tones work
together very well i did not have that
problem to me it just all went together
beautifully and i just had such a
[ __ ] good time with this and i just
like laughed out loud so many times it's
one of the funniest horror comedies i've
ever seen
and so i feel like it really needs a
wider audience so i'm glad that shutter
added it because i think a lot of people
will see it it has a five skull rating
on there there's one crabby [ __ ]
again that just gave it one skull and
they were just like i don't get the love
i hated it but everybody else was just
like this movie's so awesome and
everybody needs to see it and i would
agree with that assessment
so this is actually i don't know if it's
the debut feature film uh but the two
directors are named mike ahern and enda
loftman they might have made a couple
movies before this but i don't know if
they were shorts
um so yeah so if this is their first
film i mean
kudos because
like i said this is a really this is one
of the best movies i've seen like in a
long time i just enjoyed this
immensely and i'm sure i will probably
watch it again at some point i might
actually even end up showing it to tom
because i feel like he'd probably think
this was super funny as well like i said
because the vibe of it is very
ghostbustersy very frighteners and he
loves uh frighteners so i probably think
uh that he'd really like this now this
does lean more into
the comedy end of things than the horror
end of things but it does have horror
elements to it like there is some gore
and uh you know things like that it has
homages to
like things like the exorcist and stuff
like that and there's kind of like gross
out sort of stuff in it too not super
gross but a little bit but it mostly is
a comedy you know what i mean like very
much like shawn of the dead it's mostly
like funny but it just has like horror
elements to it
so uh i didn't really recognize that
many of the actors in this uh the best
known one probably will be will force is
it fort or forte i can't remember the
dude from he's on snl and 30 rock and
stuff like that i'd seen him in like
various other things so he's in this
like as kind of the antagonist
but the other ones uh the main character
rose is actually played by maeve higgins
who i guess she'd had some bit parts
prior to this but is mostly known as a
comedian and she is [ __ ] great i just
love her character in this she's just so
so lovable and everybody in this like
all the good guy characters i think the
reason why this movie works and why i
enjoyed it so much was just you couldn't
help but love these characters it's just
they're quirky but not like an annoying
kind of way it's just i don't know it's
like really hard to explain it's just
it's so
i don't know it's just so wholesome and
charming and lovable but i don't know
it's just like i said it's hard to
explain
so here's the setup of the movie now it
starts out with these really awesome
like cheesy
vhs things with this guy who is like a
paranormal investigator and it turns out
that he had done like this vhs series
um you know exploring the paranormal or
whatever it's called and he's like
explaining like how to hunt ghosts and
what to do about them and things like
that
so this turns out
to be to have been the dad of our main
character now our main character rose
um she has a spiritual gift she can see
ghosts and can help them like you know
go into the light or into the afterlife
or whatever
but uh because when she was a kid
she was working with her dad like on a
paranormal like investigation where they
were doing like a sort of not
necessarily an exorcism but kind of like
that
and it went wrong
and her dad sort of ended up dying as a
result of this thing so she blames
herself and she said after that she
wasn't going to use her what they call
talents with a capital t
anymore
so she's kind of like you know in her
30s or 40s or whatever and she's been
working as a driving instructor in rural
ireland
and as i said she's you know she's
single she lives alone uh she seems like
a very
like sweet
lovable woman like she's not bitter or
cranky or anything like that she's just
a very very nice lady
and it's just kind of funny they're like
establishing her life where she just
comes home and is eating like frozen
lasagna and she's sitting on one of
those bouncy ball things in her kitchen
like in her underwear and [ __ ] like that
it's just like really really funny
so uh they establish oh and by the way
this is not set in the present day
necessarily they don't really go that
much into it but from the looks of the
technology like the cell phones and
stuff it looks like maybe it's supposed
to be early 2000s but they don't ever
say like specifically when it is it
doesn't really matter all that much
anyway
but uh so they show that she still gets
numerous numerous messages and phone
calls from people who want her you know
who know her from her famous dad like
the paranormal investigator and so
they're always trying to call her for
help if they're having some kind of
haunting but she always just kind of
like ignores it she's just like look i'm
a driving instructor now if you need me
to help you to learn to drive then i'll
do that but i'm not gonna do that uh
that ghost [ __ ] anymore because
something bad happened last time so she
gets all these messages and she ignores
them now it turns out though that
there's this other guy named martin his
name is actually martin martin
and he's also a very sweet dude and his
wife bonnie has passed away
but she doesn't want to leave the damn
house and bonnie was probably uh
seemingly really a piece of work when
she was alive because she just keeps you
never see her but she keeps like kind of
berating him from the afterlife like she
lays out his clothes for work in the
morning and if he goes to pick a
different one she has like she starts
throwing [ __ ] around and like hitting
him with stuff so she's like kind of
abusive like from the afterlife it's not
funny but i mean it's kind of plain
funny but you know what i mean so she's
kind of like doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
putting messages in his morning toast
and [ __ ] like that
so this has been going on for a while
and he's a little brow beaten but he's
sort of like reluctant to get rid of her
because you know that's still his
ex-wife and he still is kind of hanging
onto her because he still presumably has
some feelings for her and feels bad
about kind of exercising her out of the
house but
it's kind of becoming unlivable just
because
the ghost is just kind of like [ __ ]
up his life constantly and he also has a
teenage daughter named sarah sarah
finally convinces him they're like she's
like look you can't live like this
anymore like mom's been dead a while um
you know she's just beating your ass
from the afterlife
why don't you call this rose lady and
you know exercise or get rid of her
and so the dad doesn't really want to do
that what he does at first he's like
well maybe i'll just go talk to rose and
uh i'll pretend that i want to learn to
drive and then uh you know she'll say no
and then i can just tell my daughter hey
i went and asked her and she said no and
that's the end of it because like i said
he's afraid to let go of his ex of his
wife
so they do so he goes and like uh you
know pretends to get a driving lesson
and the two of them kind of hit it off a
little bit it's just kind of like a
little there's kind of a little cute
like little tension between them and
stuff and she's kind of like oh he's
kind of cute and blah blah then she goes
she also has a pregnant sister and they
kind of like talk about it as well
so this almost has a this almost has
like a veneer of like paranormal rom-com
but not in an irritating way like i said
it's mostly like because there's like a
little love story type situation going
on there too but
it's mostly like the paranormal stuff
now so so we have kind of like three
tendrils going on you have
uh rose's thing at the beginning and
then you have martin and his you know
dead wife and the daughter and then you
have the third uh thread in this tale
which is a dude played by will forte
uh named christian winter
now christian winter was an american pop
star who had uh who was like a one-hit
wonder looked like sometime in maybe the
late 70s or early 80s like judging from
the the bits of the video of this
today's show this song called cosmic
woman which is just like
just imagine like the cheesiest i mean
it's hilarious like the [ __ ] is
hilarious so they show like parts of his
video and there's kind of like a little
news for the job like he had this
massive hit like back in the day
but after that
you know no one really cared anymore so
he's like a one hit wonder so he moved
to this castle in ireland because of
like some tax shelter situation so he's
been living like nearby
and he's decided as you do that he's
kind of just sick of being
this keep being a joke they call him
like one hit winter because that's his
last name
and he's so he decides that he is going
to make a pact with satan uh to be
wealthy and famous again
so that's what he said that's why he's
the antagonist like that's what he's
doing he also has a wife named claudia
who
is knows what he's doing
uh because she wants in on it too
because she wants you know the money and
fame and everything but she's just like
constantly nagging and constantly like
not really thinking it's all that big a
deal like there's one scene in the
beginning i hate to like spoil too much
about it but some of the [ __ ] in here is
just like so funny that i can't help
myself but one scene at the beginning so
to do the pact with satan he needs to
sacrifice a virgin right so he has found
one and kind of has her in suspended
animation because it has to be done like
on the blood moon it's this whole thing
so he kidnapped one and he's kind of
keeping her in his castle like in
suspended animation and his wife
accidentally and i'm not going to say
like what the specifics of this are
but his wife accidentally
makes her explode
so
he gets mad and he has to go get another
one like at short notice it so initially
at first you think these kind of three
stories aren't really connected all that
much well the you know the the martin
and rose story is connected because he
calls her up to get rid of his wife
but then
the uh then the whole satanic pop star
angle comes into it too because he loses
that his first virgin and he sets his
sights on sarah martin's daughter you
know he's going to kidnap her and she's
going to be the sacrifice at which point
rose has to come in and like help him
save his daughter like from being
sacrificed to satan
so there's that whole situation going on
too like i said it sounds like an absurd
premise and it is but the way that it's
pulled off is just like so
i know it's just it's just so lovable
and it's just so charming and so funny
that
i don't know like like i said the will
forte part like with the satanist
because i know that he's got i haven't
seen a great deal of stuff that he's in
but
you know he's sort of known for doing
these kind of over-the-top roles and the
role that he does here as christian
winter is absolutely over the top but i
think not as much as some of his other
roles so if you are thinking that he's
going to be like some screechy like like
i saw one thing say it was kind of like
adam sandler i'm like not no it's not
like that but
it is over the top like absurd but it
kind of reminded me of like you know the
british version of the office where he
showed the like the new wave videos that
he made like back in the old days it's
kind of like that like except like a
little bit cheesier but it's just like
the whole thing with him sacrificing the
thing and then like having a regular
life like with this naggy wife that's
constantly trying to scam free chinese
food and stuff like that not not really
caring that much about what he's doing
she's like would you just hurry up why
don't we just kill the [ __ ] come on
it's like what when are we gonna be rich
and you know so it's all that kind of
stuff and she's just constantly berating
him so so there's that going on but i
think the strength of this movie really
is
the sort of relationship that develops
between
rose and martin it has kind of a nice
message too because
martin uh he was kind of like afraid
like i said to get rid of his of bonnie
like his dead wife even though she was
constantly like kicking the [ __ ] out of
him and nagging himself for like from
the afterlife and throwing dishes and
whatnot and uh but he was still kind of
like hanging on to her and so you know
his arc being to learn to let go of of
the past
and uh you know rose kind of had the
same thing going because she had to get
to a point where she because she didn't
want to help martin at first because
like i said the last time she used her
talents for
paranormal like you know you know
helping ghosts go pass on to the
afterlife you know her dad ended up
dying and so she has kind of like
she's like afraid to use her gifts like
to their full ability because she's
afraid something bad's gonna happen so
it takes like a lot for her to
sort of come back and get that
confidence again
and sort of you know uh get to a point
where she's not afraid to
use her to use her gifts uh the way she
used to so it's kind of nice the two of
them and like i said the two of them
play off each other so well i want to
say too that one of the best parts is
and again this is kind of like a comp
like probably too complicated to get
into in the review but
one of the things they have to do to
help sarah not get sacrificed is
basically rose has to like channel all
these different ghosts into martin and
then like she needs to get some
ectoplasm ectoplasm
so
so he actually uh i hadn't seen him in
anything else i was i've he's been in
some other stuff but he was great like
because he had to like embody
all these other people and then toward
the end when he has to channel his
ex-wife bonnie oh my god that was like
one of the funniest [ __ ] parts just
like the physicality
and i don't know if he actually did
a lot of the voices himself i'm
suspecting not but if a lot of it's
dubbed it was dubbed really really well
because it actually does look like he's
doing a lot of the voices um but just
like the physicality of him like going
back and forth between all these
different personalities is different
ghosts like inhabit him and especially
when his ex-wife inhabits his body is
just
fantastic so the first couple you know
the first couple thirds to look you know
the first two acts of this
are basically like kind of just like a
sweet
paranormal
rom-com
you know type of thing you know with the
satanic element coming into it but then
like the third act goes like pretty
crazy like when they're actually like
racing against time to like stop this uh
stop this satanic ritual where sarah's
gonna get sacrificed and like by the end
of it it's just like going
completely nuts and it's just hilarious
and i love it you know so and and i
really love like the the kind of cgi at
the end it's just everything about this
movie
was a delight i just thought it was so
fun and just so and it just has such a
cool like little emotional core to it
like i said it's very much
a lot of people have compared it to
ghostbusters it is kind of like that but
you know
i saw a variety i think they called it
like the tea cozy ghostbusters which is
a pretty good description but it has its
own thing going on it's almost kind of
like ghostbusters but
with the sort of shawn of the dead type
sensibility
and you know just a drier sense of humor
i guess
and the effects aren't was over the top
it's not like because i feel like
ghostbusters more like an action comedy
whereas this is kind of more like
you know more low-key you know what i
mean it's not it doesn't really go over
the top with you know crazy [ __ ] going
on until the end and even then it's not
really that much over the top but
there's just i don't know just the tone
of this just hit exactly right for me
it's like so so funny i found myself
just like busting out laughing like a
bunch of times just so many parts of
this are great like i said i think one
of my favorite things was martin like
channeling his ex-wife like toward the
end which was just it was just like so
[ __ ] funny i just couldn't even stay
at it but i just like the way he stood
and like cigarette comes out of his
mouth like from nowhere like there's
just like the way he talked it was just
like so [ __ ] funny so there was that
but it's just like the the
kind of interstitials they have like
with the vhs tapes of rose's dad like
with uh one of his
vhs series about exploring the
paranormal it's like they would pop that
in every now and then because sometimes
she'd be watching them and it's like
those were [ __ ] funny because they're
like super low-key and they're talking
about have you ever you know eaten
cheese and felt weird afterwards you
might have eaten a ghost it's like it's
just like very very dry like the way
they say everything like it's just
completely a matter of fact and it's
just like so so funny to me but yeah
it's honestly
and another thing too and i've seen i
watched a couple other reviews of this
and weirdly a couple of them that
weren't even like presumably like
related to one another had seen one
another a couple of them said they're
not you know it's like we're not usually
into sequels or anything but they would
absolutely watch a sequel to this
because the way that it ends it doesn't
necessarily set it up for a sequel but
you could make one if you wanted to like
you could expand
the universe out and honestly if they
did that i would actually really like to
see that just because the characters
particularly the characters of rose and
martin are just so
lovable and they're so great together
like they make such the chemistry
between them is so good and so funny
that i would totally watch a whole other
movie about those two like going on more
like paranormal shenanigans and
investigations and stuff that would be
[ __ ] amazing i don't know if that
will ever happen because as i said this
was
i this did not play in theaters here as
far as i know it did kind of the
festival circuit it might have showed i
believe i saw that it showed like a
limited release maybe like theatrically
in the uk
but i don't think it got anything like a
theatrical release in the us and to be
honest even though i saw it mentioned
on uh you know some a bunch of horror
sites it seems like it didn't really get
a lot of mainstream attention and that's
really a shame because this movie
is just so i mean
i kind of feel like anybody that would
watch it it's just i i just can't see
how you wouldn't love it it's just it's
adorable and and i don't mean that like
in a twee like way kind of way or
anything like that it's just a really
sweet movie but it also has like really
[ __ ] up like it says it even it also
has like exploding children
so there's that but i don't know so
there's just something about it and i
kind of wish that i'm so glad that
shutter finally picked it up because i
really really hope this gets a wider
release it's just so so fun and just
talking about it for this review i just
watched it yesterday and i was like just
talking about it for this review makes
me want to watch it again which i don't
usually do i don't usually watch a movie
like you know two days in a row or
anything but i think i totally would
with this one because there might have
been like some jokes and [ __ ] going on
in the background that i missed and so
now i have to like pick all that up pick
up on it so i think i maybe will watch
this again maybe not maybe not today but
maybe maybe soon you know before shutter
gets rid of it but if you have shutter
please watch this it's so so funny
especially if you like horror comedies
like i said and if you're a fan of any
of the ones that i mentioned previously
then you will probably love this uh like
i said it does seem like 98 of people
that watched it loved it and i you know
i'm totally on board that dream this was
just this was so good and so fun and
just so entertaining and easily one of
the best horror comedies i've seen in
the last few years and uh so let me know
if you've watched it what you thought
about it if you thought it was funny um
i hope you do because i'm you know i'm
putting myself out there like
recommended but like i said i'm pretty
confident in saying that most people
would think this was funny as well so
yeah let me know what you thought about
it in the comments and that will do it
for this flickers of fear i will see you
guys on the next one bye